Roger Kennedy you've got a book out
called orders from France before we talk
about the actual book why are we hearing
so much about France these days
well they had a revolution 200 years ago
I guess for starters
their revolution had an effect upon us
and we have a feeling that our
revolution had a little effect upon them
I suppose the major reason is that we
and the French have a kind of on-again
off-again romance
we started out of course French and
Indian Wars and burning villages and
Deerfield and in every kid to learn
American history thinks about those
terrible Indians and those terrible
Frenchmen burning us up nobody paid much
attention to us bringing them up I'm
afraid when we were kids then they were
then the the desperate enemy then during
the Revolutionary War they were our
allies in achieving our independence
people like Lafayette then lawful who
laid out Washington DC were our allies
and friends and our heroes there were
more French people at Yorktown than
there were Americans nearly three times
as many French people in the armed
forces at Yorktown as Americans and we
had a we had a romance that lasted it's
from the end of our war of independence
1783 through the first year or two of
the French Revolution when they were
when we thought they were going to have
a kind of revolution like ours which is
a sort of a safe and sane not too
disruptive one and then it got out of
hand and they cut off their king's head
and Americans were shocked we hadn't cut
off our king's head of course the
British had a little earlier and the
French did a little later but there
wasn't a king available to decapitate
for us so after the French eliminated
their king and really had a profound
social revolution Americans of the
Thomas Jefferson George Washington
Alexander Hamilton sort that were really
moderate people
began in differing degrees for each of
them to withdraw their sense of that
affinity to France and then within a
very few years we went to war with
France though we never declared it but
Dean 97 and about 1799 we and the French
were in an active naval war in the
Caribbean and in a really very very
interesting way that we're just
beginning to learn about now as archives
become available the story is that the
second independent Republic in the
Western Hemisphere was established by
the blacks in what is now called Haiti
than Santo Mag they declared their
independence and achieved it by their
own strength from the French and the
Spanish who had the other end of the
island fought off a British expedition
which attempted to put them back both in
slavery and in colonial status and the
American government then led by George
Washington and Alexander Hamilton led by
the Federalists most of whom were
northerners and many of whom were not
slave owners that government supported
the black government led by Toussaint
L'Ouverture the great hero of headon
independence and we went to war with
France too in many ways to defend the
sea lanes between us and that second
independent Republic American ships
fired on French ships sank a lot of them
we actually battered the shore of Haiti
with our naval guns to protect to sense
black army and that story which is
almost totally unknown to Americans is
I'm afraid not so well known to Haitians
either because after 1800 a new American
government came into power led by Thomas
Jefferson largely predominated by the
interests of southern slaveholders and
that government reversed the position of
the former American government
cut off aid to 2 cent entered into an
agreement with Napoleon then in charge
of France that we would not resist if
the French sought to reestablish both
slavery and colonialism there in the
Caribbean and our American fleet was
withdrawn the French succeeded in
landing an immense force led by
Napoleon's brother-in-law and his sister
they succeeded in defeating Toussaint
and kidnapping him taking him to die in
France probably starving him to death
and the long desperate decline of the
island of Haiti which has led it to
being one of the poorest nations in the
world today it was then one of the
riches that decline began as a
succession of expeditions and military
campaigns ravaged that countryside the
part of the story that is both
intriguing and in some ways terrible is
that the first independent republic in
the Western Hemisphere the United States
and the second the independent country
of Santo mang now now Haiti did not form
a continuing alliance if they had the
whole history of independence movements
in this country in this hemisphere would
have been entirely different but because
we were still very much a slaveholding
country dominated by a government led by
mr. Jefferson one of our great heroes
those slaveholders simply could not
tolerate the presence of a free black
revolted slave Republic in the
hemisphere so we formed an alliance of a
more disagreeable sort at that time with
a neo-colonial imperial French
government to reimpose colonialism in
the Caribbean that's one of the sorry
year periods after that the story gets I
guess a little pleasanter the French
didn't reappear as an imperial power in
the Western Hemisphere until another
chapter that I guess is in orders from
France because I think the story is kind
of interests
after Waterloo after Napoleon was
defeated finally by the British and
Germans his whole staff college from the
Battle of Waterloo came to Philadelphia
the generals and about 27 Colonels and
seven or eight generals intending to
invade Texas this story appears here
it's a kind of a loony story and they
did in fact invade Texas there were
mostly generals captain's Colonels and
and darn few of foot soldiers but they
had a the beginnings of a successful
alliance with the Pirates in the Gulf of
Mexico and these French very
distinguished military leaders could
succeeded in building three or four
forts along the Trinity River and this
is whether yards in this story in this
book and at that point the United States
government the French government were
again in alliance but against this
collection of freebooting independent
Bonapartists who were trying to
re-establish a government in Texas which
would serve as the basis upon which they
could collect enough money from silver
mines and otherwise to go liberate
Napoleon from Saint Helen of the island
in the South Atlantic where he was being
held
second-rate almost at the end third one
was during our own Civil War and most
Americans seem to forget that at that
point the French reappeared as a
colonial power and installed Maximilian
as the Emperor of Mexico that was a
French operation not a Spanish one
poor old Maximilian got left in the
lurch by Napoleon the third the Emperor
of France again in the 1860s when we got
through with our own Civil War and
General Grant and others made it clear
to the French that we wanted no part of
the re-imposition of a French Empire in
the Western Hemisphere so we were almost
at the brink of war one more time when
the French withdrew leaving Napoleon
leaving leaving Maximilian
to be dealt with by the Mexicans who
lined him up against the wall and a
firing squad took care of the last
French Western Hemisphere Imperial
adventure that's I'm just telling you a
series of stories that show up in orders
from France but we've had these these
periodic explosive friend and foe
relationships with him ultimately of
course in World War one Lafayette we are
here said John J Pershing we were back
in alliance with the French one more
time American Expeditionary Forces in
Flanders and in France in 1917 18 were
the final force that tipped over the
first world war then in a kind of a
balanced condition and freed France once
again in Normandy in 1943 four Americans
freed France one more time I suppose
today the story is that we are in once
again in a kind of an uneasy
relationship with Western Europe in
general with the French in particular in
which we confront together what threats
we perceived have perceived since the
Second World War is common to us all
Western Europe and we share common
apprehension about the intentions of the
Russians now as the Russians seem to be
less fearful we in the French are of
course coming apart again so it's a long
that's a terribly long answer it what a
nice kind of television program this is
that you can give a long answer Roger
Kennedy you though don't write looks
necessarily for a living you are the
director of the Museum of American
History Smithsonian mm-hmm how long have
you done that ten years why are you
doing it
oh cuz it's fun that's an easy one
I believe very strongly in the role of
the Smithsonian which is to increase and
diffuse knowledge that's what its
Charter says that means
we have a franchise to learn about
things that interest us we have a
franchise to collect things that tell
other people about the things that
interests us and may interest other
people too and then probably more
important we have the responsibility to
try to talk to people about it which is
what you and I are doing now we're we're
talking about a series of things that
are important to the American people and
that's what we do at the museum every
day I've passed the been there many
times but I've also passed it almost
daily at 14 to the Constitution this
huge building explain what I do
well we have 19 million tourists that
come to this town every year yeah 17 to
19 but how many of those come to see you
6 or 7 million we're we're almost alone
in in American public institutions in
that we're not we're not fighting for
for a bigger share of the gate we're not
looking to increase our audience which
is kind of strange
no Nielsen's for us our situation is
that we are probably dealing with about
as many people effectively talking with
in conversation so to speak imparting
whatever it is that we've sought to
learn making available primary artifacts
to about as many as we can handle twenty
thirty thousand on a good strong day so
that what we're engaged in doing now and
where the fun is is to try to do a
better job of talking to the American
people about their experience their
common experience their their history it
isn't just a matter of objects on a wall
with labels next to them or even the
famous things that ten years ago or even
20 years ago when you and I probably
wandered into that kind of place for the
first time we then went and it was
conventional to go and do the first
lady's count or do the Hope Diamond or
do the spirit of st. Louis as if you had
a kind of a checklist and you were going
to or a menu and you were going to eat
your way through the Smithsonian that's
a pretty dumb way
to experience a contemporary museum
because what museums at least our place
is about is about narrative that is
we're about stories were about
connecting objects by yarns true yarns
that give them some sense in either in
juxtaposition where to tense ibly
unrelated objects really have
connections or by putting them together
actually in the way that you and I would
do if we were telling each other
something about something we cared about
we would tend to find an object or draw
a picture or do something that
Illustrated what we were doing so we're
we're in the storytelling business
traditionally that's what history is
anyway give us an idea of the scope of
all this sure I think of things I'm
particularly proud of there's a
internationally celebrated wonderful
show about the movement of rural black
Americans to the urban north called
Field a factory which presents a story
which happens to be about black people
but which we find and this is kind of
interesting too we find that our
visitors who share with each other and
with almost of the rest of us the
experience of having gone from someplace
where we grew up and thought we belonged
some other place where we had to make a
new kind of life Washington is full of
people like that we share that sense of
disruption and having to make a new life
and if that story is about it happens
just those blacks who move from the
rural South to the urban north and just
before World War two what happens in
that exhibition is that grandparents
talk to grandchildren about their own
experience of leaving the church in the
school and
may your landscape and the smells and
sounds of the country or the small town
and moving to some other place where
they had to find new churches and new
schools and new civic organizations and
new beauty shops and new barber shops
and a new grocer and getting established
that show therefore is about all of us
so being about some of us I'll give you
another couple of instances shall I keep
on going well let me first ask you how
much money do you spend any years oh
sure good good question we spend about
15 to 18 million bucks a year of which
the Congress puts up Oh
twelve twelve thirteen this year will
raise privately from corporations
foundations and a few individuals about
that much again about ten or eleven
million this is a big year for us we're
doing that because this is the year that
we are spending a lot of money trying to
engage with the history science helping
people one thing we're doing happens to
be this thing you and I are doing right
now the Information Age what it means to
have this enormous a mass of information
brought to us every day just like this
what are we going to do with all this
information how do we sort it out what's
significant what is insignificant what
does it mean to Americans if this kind
of dazzling profusion of of sound bytes
and info bytes reaches them advertising
information news in all these media what
does that do to our sense of what is
real and what is and what is real when
kids shoot each other because they've
seen so much of violence in television
and in the movies we're in the
television and the movies nobody hurts
we have a sense that reality is being
distorted by this information revolution
we're living in so we're trying to deal
with that in our place it means that
you've got to use a lot of the geared
cameras and all of the rest of it in
order to talk about the key
we also know that once this is doing to
capital markets what it's doing to that
is dared destabilized more volatile than
they ever were before and I suppose in
innumerable ways reaching right down to
the checkout counter at the supermarket
where you've got a little piece of
electronic gear that records that
records what you bought that they could
record what you're wearing that day or
the color of your eyes that day it could
be taking a picture of you on your way
out their innumerable ways in which
information is being collected
transmitted and it affects us enormously
so we're trying to talk about that tell
the audience the original reason we
invited you here and there's so much to
talk about and we're going to be jumping
all over the place but hopefully our
audience will be somewhat intrigued by
this book orders from France by Roger G
Kennedy a man who has been an NBC
correspondent who has worked in the
Eisenhower administration for the Labor
hgw and htw departments he honestly I
was in the Department of Justice is the
lawyer for a while too which helped a
little with this book why oh because our
the books about us and the French
between 1780 and 1820 well us and the
French between those two dates were in
the process of making a constitution we
made one we created one French made a
whole series of them they had the the
story I like to think about it
Talleyrand said to a friend who
Talleyrand in 1848 who had been present
in the forming of the french good for
you friend the French Revolution was
then a very elderly gentleman and the
guy so I'm coming out of his carriage
and he said to him sir Marquis or
whatever he was by that time isn't this
the 48th government to which you have
sworn final allegiance and he said I
believe it is the 49th and I do hope
it's the last they've had they've had a
lot of changes of of their mode of
governing we had fewer but as a lawyer I
suppose that one of the
things that you learn about as the
Supreme Court this very week once again
rien structured this you learn about the
importance of continuities the notion is
that the law is something that lasts
longer than opinions do and in the
period in which our nation took its
current form and the French went through
any number of efforts to to form a
country continuities were were more
disrupted even than they were in our
time even more in than in the 60s even
more than in other periods of turmoil in
our life the sense of there being
something that you could count on was
vehemently ripped and torn so that our
founding fathers and the French founding
fathers and mothers had to make
something new in the presence of an
abyss of the unknown they didn't have a
set of continuities that kind of carried
them through their tough times they had
in a sense decapitated a king because
they had gotten rid of a king and a
parliament and they had to form
something brand new so what we have here
is a period of immense courage and
immense resourcefulness and of course a
lot of military adventure because when
the old continuities are disrupted it
leaves holes into which force brute
force intrudes that's what happens in
human society when the cops aren't on
the beat violence will spread out and
when the cops so to speak in
international terms are not present to
sustain an order what happens thereafter
is that innumerable burly people with
the big ideas will form their own armies
their own fleets pirates privateers new
governments form and this period 1780 to
1820 is appear
in which ours was a successful adventure
the people who led our revolution could
easily have failed after all Latin
America was a story at that time of a
people of equal skill extraordin is this
there are a lot of stories in that book
about Miranda who was the founder of
Venezuela dismissed by many American
historians as it as it as a unsuccessful
leader but he had all of the qualities
of George Washington and some more to
because he had a wonderful sense of
humor when he was a pretty good
architect which George Washington was
not very good architect had no sense of
here working very great man but we can
too we tend to look at success
particularly in the city of Washington
and and we tend to assume that the
successful ones had some had greater
merit than the unsuccessful ones and in
the case of the Latin Americans there
are people of immense heroism and great
skill some of whom I've tried to write
about in the book who who didn't happen
to be successful something went wrong
they didn't have among other things the
Allies that the United States did which
takes me back to France
our primary ally ask you little things
about this book what period did you
write in what period did you write it
you're not not to be not the book when
did you know nineteen I finished a book
called architecture men women and money
in nineteen eighty two or three I guess
the idea of that book was that if you're
interested in large objects which I am
buildings houses and the like you got to
sort out where the money came from
because buildings are expensive
architectures of public art and this
book has a fair amount about
architecture in it too but in the course
of writing that I came upon a whole
series of very interesting characters
that didn't make it into big-time
history architects among them
and from 83 to about 87 or so I want
1480 that's right 1983 buddy 87 I was
working on that
while we were in the course of course
we're reorganizing the museum along
other lines so it was a hobby in a way
it was a an opportunity to put together
a whole range of kinds of things that
interest me I'm interested in economics
I've made my living as a banker I'm
interested in continuities in the law
and I'm very interested in American
history how did you write it I mean did
you write it at home with your office
yeah I airplanes the portable the
portable word processor has been in a
way a boon I guess yeah I've used one of
those oh yeah sure on airplanes oh yeah
that's the only time to edit the do that
the time to write books is at home I
think between 6:00 and 10:00 in the
morning if you've got a if you got the
secretaries that will keep it covered at
the office and tell everybody that
you're busy doing something else you
couldn't write books in the morning the
time to edit is on airplanes when you're
on your way to make speeches somewhere
because then nobody can find you the
greatest the most terrible thing that's
happened recently of course is that
telephones have been installed on
airplanes which is a it's a great heresy
if they can't call you they can't call
you that's exactly right but there's
always the temptation to call them but
you got to fight off there but at 7:15
for three minutes yeah that's exactly
right
somebody rich that you're going to call
up and reverse the charges that's right
you're gonna have a puckish delight to
do that I've been finding that if you're
really interested in the subject matter
if you really really do like it and
you're a little too busy you're
attending you will tend to do seven or
eight or ten drafts and you'll do them
on the beach or in an airplane or in the
car if your wife or as a friend or
somebody's willing to drive that's what
you do
I don't think it's easy I've never had
the opportunity to find out but I think
it'd be very hard to write books that
are that try to connect real people to
real experience if you were just writing
books I would find that tough because
every day somebody comes along in the
museum or in my business which is
banking and says gee I had this nifty
idea today and I've been learning about
that and you say to yourself well that's
that's interesting I wonder how that
connects to my subject so I find the the
origins of investment Investment Banking
is in that book let me ask you about
this and right in the first page oh you
have and the audience will see this up
close in just a moment you dedicate this
to McGeorge Bundy yes why well he's my
friend but he was also my boss for 10
years where I was the vice president for
finance and then later for the Arts as
well at the Ford Foundation from 1971 I
guess to 79 and Mac Bundy was my boss he
was also my teacher in that I had the
guest the good fortune of getting hit by
truck in Central Park in 1972 I was on
my bicycle and the truck was not legally
in the park as a result of that I wasn't
very ambulatory we've broken legs and
arms and stuff and that meant that
somebody had to drive me to work Mac who
was the president that Mac Bundy was the
president of the Ford Foundation had a
car that's what presidents have and so
he simply began picking me up and
driving me home at night which would
have been very nice all by itself but
then we got kind of used to talking to
each other in the morning in the evening
and what I got out of that was the
greatest course in American contemporary
history he's imaginable because
he would be reading the paper and we
would talk about what we was reading in
the paper and then we would talk about
what we were doing in the foundation
which generally had to do with a whole
lot of things that were pretty central
to American life in the in the 70s it
was a great adventure Mac Bundy is the
smartest man I ever met he had been of
course Jack Kennedy's chief of staff and
the White House national security
adviser rather and did the same thing
for Lyndon Johnson as the president of
the Ford Foundation he believed as I do
that philanthropy exists to make a
difference to do things that are not
easy and to take on problems that are
that nobody has a franchise on and
therefore for ten years he taught me
first of all a lot about how to look at
the world and secondly he taught me a
lot about how it was possible to do a
lot of things even though people told
you you were foolish or that somebody
powerful wouldn't like it or that you
know that the system wouldn't
accommodate it and I think while we
struck out a lot of things we at least
tried a lot of things and some are
successful so when I got around to
thinking about a world in which founding
fathers with real courage made something
new happen that wouldn't have happened
as Donnelly started a new country but
laid out in the Northwest Ordinance the
possibility that you could actually form
a whole new society on purpose
rationally that you could try to do that
I thought gee
that's the kind of thing that Mac tried
to do tries to do I suppose one further
note we human beings are very fallible
we make a lot of mistakes we try to
learn from our mistakes but in the
founding years 1780 to 1820 and I think
in the Ford Foundation's great period
that is the 1970s there was a continuing
sense that even though you would you
would make mistakes and even though it
was perfectly possible to say I made a
mistake you keep trying and you keep
tackling the tough ones that's what the
founding fathers did so no way this is a
sort of old-fashioned patriotic book
which says not bad not bad we did pretty
well we we blew it from time to time but
we did pretty well so it's really as a
book about even though it says orders
from France it's a book about America
yeah it's about us in the French at a
period in which we were both
representing the the pinnacle of the
most hopeful period in the modern age I
think the 18th century was a time in
which Alexander Hamilton Thomas
Jefferson George Washington James
Madison in their very different ways it
was very different people all felt that
if you if you put your mind to it and
your energy to it and we're willing to
put your career on the line you could
make a positive for difference in human
affairs and so across the water did
debris so and Mirabeau the leaders of
the french revolution after them came a
lot of bloodier characters it's true but
there was a moment of hope it's what I
call in the book the party of hope it's
the party of people who who
believe that it is possible to affect
human affairs for the better I continue
to think that is true I don't think that
merely acquiescing and the inevitable is
a very noble way to live either in this
city or in any other city somewhere and
I can't
I should have put a mark but you write
about James Monroe oh yeah he's back
there in is a boring man
well now you kind of messed me up
because I was going to ask you the
question if I could find that neckline
the way you wrote him up in here yeah
you wrote him up as if there was and I'm
gonna get you can do fine no I'm not
gonna do fine what I'm about to say I'm
gonna get myself in trouble but it
wasn't the boring part but I was it was
a further description of James Monroe it
sounded like what some critics say about
George Bush Oh boring man in this sense
me you talking I'm having a very safe
period yeah yeah absolutely well by
boring I met this poor fella
what would you seem like if you came
after George Washington certainly the
most impressive president we ever had
just taken as that say nothing of being
an extraordinary war leader in a very
wise man Thomas Jefferson certainly the
most intellectually competent of all of
the presidents of the United States in
terms of breath John Adams an
extraordinary man James Madison who was
both witty skillful shrewd and charming
he was you could not dislike James
Madison you you really could not to say
nothing of his wife who was a all-time
charmer and then comes poor old James
Monroe James Monroe's chief virtue was
that he had survived successfully the
the political Wars of the state of
Virginia he had been shunted aside by
Jefferson and Madison he wanted to be
President eight years earlier and Thomas
Jefferson and Madison saw to it that he
wasn't and that Madison was instead
he was the last of the of the Virginia
dynasty he was very tall very stately I
see where you're coming from with with
respect to this he was very well well he
was I would have said it was very well
bred except that he made himself into
the appearance of what George Bush
doesn't have to make himself into the
appearance of being because George Bush
was born into being yet James Monroe was
a very small farmer's son who made his
own way whereas George Bush was born
into a kind of suburban national out
bourgeois class to use the French term
out of that meaning comfortably well-off
people who have been comfortably
well-off for quite a period of time let
me read a line that I remember I found
it good freeze this mayor because I
talked long enough you'd find that may
or may not help yeah sure a so-called
era of good feelings Monroe preside it
was a time of exhaustion among political
factions of nervous irritability without
the release of passion hmm yes
then no great causes stirred the blood
and there seemed to be no further
necessities for heroic action the
founding fathers had done their majestic
work and I guess based on what we've
been reading a lot about the first six
months of the George Bush administration
and the last eight years okay I I'll
give you a guess I'm very certain about
James Monroe yeah it doesn't have to be
sure I'm by no means sure about George
Bush but I can offer you a couple of
hypotheses about that the fearless state
treading on the 1980s instead in the
1780s in the first place my own view is
that George Bush has sure-footed lee
found his way through thicket of
difficulties by making it look
remarkably easy this first six months in
the age of publicity and celebrity and
the manufactured stories and who
manufactured the the the the general
circumstances in which we find ourselves
do I don't use the term the media except
more broadly than television it includes
radio and everything else too much
information too quickly disposed of too
easily handled by handlers and too easy
technically to concentrate and focus
produces news events under those
circumstances it is very easy for a
president to go from news event to news
event and get very little done my own
sense of it is that that George Bush has
actually done quite a good deal and in
fact that the that the build of of
events the the basis laid is going to be
historically viewed as very considerable
after all the competition is pretty
tough competition out there for public
attention mr. Gorbachev is one of the
masters of the century maybe of the last
couple of centuries we are dealing with
a major figure in world history with mr.
Gorbachev not just sort of any old
Russian leader that's a tough guy to
compete against in for the public eye
but it is also true that these events of
the last six months are more wracking
more startling more staggering in their
changes almost as staggering is the
events of the 1780s to 1820 we're
dealing here with great George Shultz
dropping a name George said said to me
oh I'm sorry about that but that could
happen in watching as I was picking up
some stuff at the deli George said to me
well he did that in his view in that of
two or three hundred don't you like the
pulp this was a this was a time in which
most of the underpinnings are shifting
in in China in Russia in religious
affairs in many many circumstances now
this is the period within which George
Bush who is not a flamboyant character
becomes president of the United States
following one of the Masters of media
handling and he's called upon to conduct
the affairs of the United States in a
way that recognizes change is not it's
not thrown into a tizzy by change
doesn't get into a [ __ ] hold and
cannot relinquish past policy now unlike
James Monroe it does seem to me that
George Bush is capable of finding very
skillful people particularly in the
State Department and altering the
circumstances he found in he said with
great care in ways that are are very
remarkable in the external affairs of
the United States can't speak for the
internal affairs the United States
wouldn't anyway because we're talking
about 70 to 80 to 80 20 yeah you won't
believe how fast time is going so
there's a lot of things to cover and I
want to see if we can get through a
number of things quickly first of all
you your background has led you through
all kinds of hallways and territories
including NBC as of correspondent what
were the years on that why in the 50s I
covered the White House's I don't know
either 2nd 3rd or 8th Street depending
on how you counted the first other guys
I covered the Supreme Court for a while
did a show called today worked on a show
called monitor on radio and produced a
batch of things above maybe I don't know
12 or 15 documentaries in the 50s and
right I guess to the end of the 50s the
beginning of the 60s beginning of
Camelot
big big documentaries that we will
remember well I worked on victory at sea
which I guess some people remember
and some hour long an hour and a half
long fix with the when the other
networks actually took an hour to talk
about something serious we had a
wonderful time it was the beginnings of
this business in which all you really
had to do is to have a good idea and it
didn't make so much money that it wasn't
impossible monitor radio there's some in
our audience that would like me who
remember monitor radio whatever happened
that why didn't it survive oh because in
a commercial system the notion that you
could talk about a story as long as the
story merits simply is unacceptable some
things that we're talking about for my
goodness four minutes or even six or
even an hour does miraculously well it's
crazy yet how are you gonna get the
commercial bites in there when did it
die it I thought I said we died but we
fell off that train about gosh I don't
remember because the management judge
did we all departed in the in about 57
or 58 it may have gone on after that I
don't recall remember yeah we didn't
feel it was exactly the same before we
go back to the book currently director
of the National Museum of American
history but a law degree from Minnesota
law school the undergraduate degree in
what from Yale political science I guess
something like that as we talked earlier
worked in the Eisenhower administration
at the Kennedy administration even the
Nixon mr. yeah yeah off and on when
there were I worked for a while when
mrs. hobby was trying to sort out what
to do about the Salk polio vaccine on
atw yeah I spent a little time on the
student loan program trying to organize
ways of getting student getting loans to
students in the early 70s and that when
Pat Moynihan and Richard Nixon and
others were working that program out I
spent some time in the Justice
Department working for warren burger who
became the chief justice and let's the
old labor department i did stuff about
migrant farm workers and things for Jim
Mitchell who was then the secretary and
for the last ten years with the museum
within ten years with the Ford
Foundation yeah I'm getting to question
what what of all this do you have you
enjoyed the most Oh always it's always
the next book that you're ready you know
I mean it's whatever it is that you're
doing next yes I like writing books a
lot I'm I'm no longer in the in the
political action period in my life I'm
trying to reflect a little bit upon that
kind of experience trying to find ways
of making the experience of my own time
life friends experience try to relate
that to that of others in the past and I
love writing books I would be unhappy if
that's all I were doing I I like very
much running what I think is the best
museum in the world I how many people
work for it oh I suppose of depends on
how you count four or five hundred we're
we're very active in the in the music
producing business we we have live
performance around the place now quite a
lot in February two performances of
Ellington alone everyday we are in the
Jazz business we are making a lot of
Records we're we're sort of a place that
tries to deal with the American
experience in contemporary terms so
that's fun but with all these I've got
to ask you this you probably maybe you
don't want to answer this point but I
mean you hear the Nixon and Bundy and
Kennedy and Eisenhower and Warren burger
yeah what's the label we put on Roger
candidate oh I don't know all-purpose
outfielder I don't know
I'm up no political aide oh I mean you
go label party no no I ran for Congress
once when I was in law school and what a
primary a Republican primary I worked
for Jimmy Carter doing things here there
I just try to be useful wherever there's
a chance to be useful I guess there's
I've seen some of the reviews on your
book and people do say and I have gone
through most do it that it it's all over
the place that jumping yeah short
vignette
and we haven't probably done it justice
in this conversation who do you think
will be the most interested in it what
kind of person do it this I wrote that
book for myself for for you for people
who have read a little history don't
regard themselves as being history
experts but people who like yarns who
have a visual sense
you see I think most of us like to
ground a theoretical principle or even a
story in a particular place I want to
talk to people who like going to
Monticello who think of mr. Jefferson
and then think about Monticello I think
about there's a lot of bellows that's
Montebello that was outside of Baltimore
wonderful place Sam Smith who defended
Baltimore in 1814 built this wonderful
villa it disappeared into suburban
sprawl but that's exactly what I mean if
you're interested in in how Baltimore
got defended and how Sam Smith managed
to make a lot of millions of dollars in
silver then you want to go to Montebello
well I'm for people who like grounding
general things in specific tangible
things I want people to go look at
Latrobe's rooms in the national capital
the doors in the TRO Benjamin Henry
Latrobe was the superintendent of the
key period of building the the capital
of the United States also put the port
it goes on the White House if you stand
in Lafayette Square in Washington DC
there are four Latrobe buildings right
within an I shot right there let alone
elsewhere Lafayette Park right across
the White House yeah four buildings yeah
but are they the church on your left
Decatur house on your right the which is
the National Trust House on the corner
the White House's porticoes are sitting
there and if you can [ __ ] an eye toward
the National Capitol you're looking at
mr. Latrobe Latrobe was the most the
most accurate observer of human behavior
that I encountered in the course of
looking at all of this territory more so
than Thomas Jefferson George Washington
and he's a kind of a link to everybody
because he as an architect who knew
every
buddy told us about everybody and had
strong opinions about everybody let's
jump very quickly I
I can't believe time loses fast did I
did I gather that you're not as big a
fan of Thomas Jefferson as some others
are in this I was I'm not as uncritical
a an admirer of everything mr. Jefferson
did as other people are but on the other
hand mr. Jefferson is so huge that's his
that's the state capital of the state of
Virginia designed by Thomas Jefferson
like the University of Virginia which is
in my view the most beautiful
construction that came from the human
hand in the history of this country the
University of Virginia was he a good
architect yeah he was a it was a good
almost everything but he was not unfair
about Aaron Burr oh yeah Aaron Burr is
one of my heroes why well because in
that have normal oh yeah I suppose
Aaron burrs a fellow who's had a bad bad
press you don't shoot the Secretary of
the Treasury
yeah as when you're vice president and
get away with that gently although of
course the it's got mr. Hamilton would
have shot him if he had the duel that's
right Oh Aaron Burr was was on bad terms
with Thomas Jefferson and that's not a
good way to good get a good press either
Aaron Burr to his credit proposed
immediate emancipation of the slaves in
1787 Aaron Burr broke a tie in favor of
continuing American connections
commercial connections in support of
Toussaint L'Ouverture
in eighteen three Aaron Burr was a a
kind of whimsical humorous cheerful
character who probably was irresponsible
in some ways but was by no means the
deep-dive villain that he's been
depicted by everybody else except maybe
gore Vidal favorite Frenchman Oh
favorite Frenchman I suppose Latrobe
Bobby he besides him Mirabeau brie so
the the party of hope the people who
tried to make
something occurred that was a beneficial
change without violence how would you
define the French maybe is there
anything to ristic so the French the
best in the country I would say I've
been best in their country French people
are wonderful I can't say that I like
dead Frenchman more than live ones but
they're certainly a bunch of dead
Frenchman in this book whom I find much
better company than I do
current French diplomacy really yeah why
well I think there's a kind of
aspiration in about the French at the
turn of the 19th century in the period
describe a kind of absence of arrogance
a sense of the possibilities for all
human kind of sharing and a common
heritage which is sharp in sharp
contrast Inge Shinto some of the less
admirable qualities of contemporary
French culture I think is closed and
vain where did that come where did the
new French culture come from who created
who's responsible for is that one I
don't know I don't know no it's really
that that that the kind of invidious
urbanity which characterizes some
aspects of Parisian French culture is
not as inviting to me as those qualities
of cosmopolitan generosity that we
shared with them in what I think is our
most wonderful period how many times
you've been to France I've been to
France enough times I don't know ten
times oh sure I suppose spent a lot did
you spend time in France for this book
yeah because there's a fair amount of
fresh research that could only be done
in Paris there's much more interchange
between the people who led the
intellectual life of the French
Revolution and people here then most
Americans have any reason to know
because a lot of those folks came here
Talleyrand bre so vulner lots of people
tell me about because I come from this
town tell me about Lafayette Oh
which Lafayette do you come from Indiana
yeah a bunch of morale I feel there are
Fayette sand Lafayette's I think there
are thirty up
when last counted ha laughy that's one
of those guys that made a great deal out
of goodwill and being seating Li sexy
and handsome he was not terribly bright
he was he was a noble soul with a with a
poor grasp on on not reality so much as
possibility or what you could actually
achieve but the nobility is what is the
center point of it and he was a he had a
tremendous sense of of the self
dramatizing possibilities of public life
he looked wonderful on a horse he was
very good in front of a crowd the way we
see him on a horse all the time I think
so probably why do we name all these
towns after well because he represented
France at its most heroic to us and he
also of course was aristocratic he
wasn't just some guy off the street
leading a revolution he was involved in
a series of revolutions but he was
always lemak key which is we sort of
like that our snobbish sense is drawn to
that kind of thing Lafayette was he had
the great virtue of coming back 50 years
after his chief exploits and making a
two-year tour it's like like Sarah
Bernhardt's last story was Lafayette
last tour he went every place you cannot
find a place in Lafayette indeed
Lafayette Indiana but Lafayette Kentucky
he went anywhere that people would
gather to lift a glass and celebrate the
achievements of the grand old men well
if you give it two years that's not just
you know Bruce Springsteen doing it
tonight earth that's of thoroughgoing
desire to make a depression and he
succeeded
Napoleon gosh Napoleon is like Napoleon
is one of those people that can only
emerge in a time when there is volcanic
disruption of the old order and there is
a place for adventurers that isn't like
or by job because gorbachev emerges from
a bureaucracy napoleon is a is an imp of
darkness in my
you he's one of those people that comes
out of the shifts when the land shifts
and and the sulfur comes out of the
ground and volcanoes erupt you get
napoleon you get somebody like that
never would have made a great career in
the old regime i doubt very much that he
would have had a successful career in
the united states are there things right
in front of our eyes that are French
that we don't realize sure New York City
Hall
Ivy just picked one the most beautiful
building in the city of New York without
any question if you can kind of blow out
of your blow away the fumes of the
Brooklyn Bridge or arrive on a Sunday
morning and you want to know what
neoclassical America was like in the
1790s with French guidance look at that
extraordinary French building sitting
down there with its glassiness its
coolness its order its repose and just
remember that all a lower Broadway
looked like that once designed by French
architects a la font do a good job of
the city sure he did a great job with
this city he would have done a even
greater job with the capital if he'd
finished its design one of the things
that's nice to know is that if you look
up there that he meant central rotunda
which nobody knows what to do with
that's a lawful idea and it was going to
be the Assembly of the people we have
the Congress and the Senate and the and
the Supreme Court but that was the place
for all the rest of us to raise our
flags and make speeches that's what that
that great hole in the center of the
Cathedral of the Capitol is for that's
law falls dream of an assemblage of the
American people a kind of a
revolutionary idea just a minute left of
all the people that you've written about
in this book both American and French
who's your favorite character I got to
go back to to a good storyteller there I
like memoirs and Benjamin Henry Latrobe
the architect left us memoirs stories
about people Jefferson madison monroe
everybody he knew them all and he told
us about them all in piquant ways that
can help us relate to them as if we
talked to them yesterday he's your
favorite American Oh probably I probably
Alexander Hamilton I would suppose maybe
Thomas Jefferson but everybody's
favorite is Thomas Jefferson so I've got
to find another friend to make friends
with well wait what was it the
especially liked about Alexander
Hamilton guts courage a determination to
leave the world better than what it was
when he found it this is what the book
looks like it's in the bookstores unless
they've sold out orders from France
Roger G Kennedy our guest he is
currently director of the National
Museum of American History at the
Smithsonian Institution here in
Washington thank you for your time thank
you